gentlemen here in round one we're
revisiting a forged and fire favorite
this
is a 1986 truck and it's also where
you'll Harvest your steel from in this
first round of competition now we're not
doing any old signature blades in your
signature style instead we've already
picked the blade for you guys to make
the fully functional friction folder
the friction folder is a blade where
whether the blade is opened or closed
friction maintains that Blade's position
good luck blade Smith's your three hour
Starts Now
my name is John Medlin I'm from St
Matthews South Carolina I have a
three-year-old named Emma and she's my
number one fan in fact she gave me a
little toy to keep in my pocket she said
I need to take it with me we'll see if
it brings any luck or not my game Planes
supported out as quick as I can get to
shave and get on the Grinders so I can
get the heat treat
look at John's tail really coming along
it's really starting to look like a
friction folder tail John looks like
he's gonna go for an edge quench pretty
good idea
I get the edge what I think would be a
good you know temp for the heat treat
Jordan number on ISO should be fine
oh dank I've got about a half inch crack
about an inch and a half from the end of
my blade
there's literally minutes left on the
clock two minutes blade Smiths oh man
I can't do much just gonna have to have
a crack in the end of it my name is Joe
Nipper from Desloge Missouri my business
partner John wigger is a forged and fire
Champion so if I don't do well I will
never hear the end of it man Joe's got a
[Music]
that is not flat on this blade is going
to cause problems in that pin area where
the friction is supposed to be I just
want to get a good
getting ready to drill my Pivot hole and
hopefully move on to heat treat
this thing's giving me fits
my best guess is it needs to go Center
Mass between my tail and where my blade
is going to start so here's the hoping
my guess is right
for a significant warp I'm gonna have to
feed it one more time that clock is
ticking it's getting down to the wire
and I need to get this done now so for
the best
better my name is Steve Coster I enjoy
taking whatever I have and making it
work if I was stranded on a desert
island and given a spoon to survive with
I would have a three-story home built in
a matter of six months I decided to
forge out a little pad on the end of the
Tang the concept is to hollow out a
little pocket where that tab would fit
in the pocket come down and stop the
Tang from going any farther into the
handle
I'm really trying to draw down as much
material on the bevels to get the edge
of the blade straight The Straight Edge
that's easier to grind easier to work
with Steve looks like he's going to go
for a quench
I don't have any warps I'm pretty happy
with things the way they turned out
three
two one
position is over
all right blade Smith's congratulations
you've made it into the second round of
this competition and now that your
blades have been tempered it's time to
turn them into fully functional friction
folders by attaching handles to them
good luck blade Smith's your three hour
Starts Now not only am I going to have
to grind this crack out but I know once
I start grinding the crack out it's
going to change the whole shape of my
blade
it looks like I got the crack all the
way out immediately my focus shifts to I
need to get this handle on this thing
it's going to be super hard to drill
this hole and know if it snaps that I'm
gonna go home
finally she just starts digging in
and I'm actually really really
clock is sticking down but my handle is
actually coming together now it doesn't
feel awful now I need to get an actual
sharp edge on my blade
those blade is a big big thick blade and
if you're going to turn that into a
folder it's going to be ginormous the
material is not coming off as fast as I
would like it but I know it's very
critical for me to do it if it takes me
a little extra time than what I plan for
that's just what I got to do I'm behind
schedule in my mind this is not where I
wanted to be I've got to start shaping
my handle
at this point I'm not looking to turn in
a perfect blade I know that's not going
to happen
still a little big yeah damn it I'm just
trying to turn a handle in that you
could actually hold at this point I'm
just not feeling like I'm going to make
that goal I really need to concentrate
on the handle I'm a little confused
right now at the geometry of the pinhole
I drilled three different holes in
different spaces in my handle material
and I can swing the blade and see where
it closes and where it opens I've got
everything together and then I realized
that I fully quenched my blade which
means I have a fully hardened blade
and a fully hardened blade can be
brittle and I really don't want my blade
to be brittle for the bumper chop I want
it to have a soft back
so I blew back my spine what Steve's
doing is he's really building for the
test that blue backing was really a
smart idea
the friction part of it works opening
and closing pretty good just the handle
is just too fat so I really need to
beat it down a little bit
five four three two one placement shut
down your machines drop your tools this
second round of competition is over
I'm happy I got something turned in but
that handle is blocky and it's not going
to be super comfortable for the judges
I'm definitely worried
blade Smiths welcome to the strength
test
to test the strength and durability of
your friction folders I'll be batoning
them into this car bumper
remember this test is all about what
that bumper does to your friction
folders and not the other way around
John you're up first you ready I'm not
as ready as I'm gonna get all right
anytime steelhead steel there's a big
chance Something's Gonna Break
especially since I had to reprofile it
and make the end so thin I'm just hoping
that it's going to make it through
foreign
well John your entire knife held up well
the mechanism works well it's it's nice
and tight in all its orientations
your Edge took some minor roll some
glinting but in total I think it held up
really well in this test well thank you
yo you're up how you feeling uh first
time for everything
it's my turn and I know this test is
going to be brutal I mean it kind of
makes my stomach turn that handles got
me really concerned
that's the biggest weakness and that's a
critical point of that blade
well Joe it held up all in one piece
very good
the blade took some roll
and you can hear it
especially out here towards the tip the
handle itself
is huge if I were to be actually
swinging this thing it would be
difficult to keep control of yeah
what do you thinking Steve I think I'm
about ready to find out I'm thinking you
are
John and Joe did really well and now
it's my turn and uh we'll see hopefully
I can get the same out of it
well Steve your Edge took some roll from
the bumper mostly at the point here
your handle is comfortable I like the
swell up here near the front it's it's
gives me my hand a place to live it all
held up it's all one piece well done
thank you very much
this is the sharpness test the seat belt
straps slice
now unlike the strength test this is all
about what the edge of your weapon will
do to these seat belt straps John you're
up first you ready yeah I'm ready let's
do this
please
[Applause]
oh good job
your Edge has some rolling there but it
did not affect the test at all it was
easy to cut through the thing I like
about this is that I can wrap my hands
around it and I can actually make it
work when I'm slicing with it and moving
it around your weapon
it will cut thank you good job Joe you
ready let's do it
good job
it's really wide in the handouts you can
see when you wrap around it continuous
use of this will put some stress on the
fingers but your edge here is sharp it
will cut thank you
all right Steve it's your turn you ready
yeah I think so
there you go
you Contour this enough to where I can
wrap my hand around so I get a good grip
with that grip it allows easier to index
and slash with it your Edge cut easily
through all the seat belt straps it is
sharp and it will cut thank you good job
yeah
blade Smiths the judge's deliberation
has been completed the blade Smith
leaving the forge is
Joe your blade didn't make the cut
show all your blades performed equally
well that it came down to the detail of
your handle construction we all felt it
was a little bit wide to be comfortable
in the hand
please surrender your friction folder
that I didn't make it through but I knew
that handle was going to be an issue if
I had five more minutes just to work on
that handle I think this would have been
a different outcome